with each new episode of the white lotus
i find myself getting more invested in
what's going on with this group of
generally unlikable characters how's
this clash of the classes this group of
entitled guests and the staff that's
there to meet their every need how will
this all play out hey guys pete here
today i'm going to be talking about the
mystery of the dead body being loaded
onto the plane in the opening scene of
the white lotus there's just two
episodes left in the limited series and
this feels like a good time to talk
about how things might fall into place a
quick warning i'm making this video
after episode 4 which means there will
be spoilers if you aren't caught up to
that point with that out of the way
let's jump in the series opened with a
flash forward of shane alone at the
airport getting ready to board a flight
to honolulu deep in thought he's kind of
nervously playing with his wedding ring
and it looks like whatever he's thinking
about has him seething as two other
travelers ask him about his trip we
learned that he was there for his
honeymoon and stayed at the white lotus
when they hear that name they say they
heard someone was killed there and he
confirms that telling them the body is
being loaded onto their flight when they
ask where his wife is he gets tired of
talking in no uncertain terms he tells
them to leave him alone he gets up he
walks to the window where we see the
casket being loaded onto the plane
that's the setup his vacation's over and
he's upset his new wife isn't joining
him on this flight and someone got
killed at the resort where he was
staying at this point the show wants you
to think that it might have been his
wife who died but that seems less and
less likely as things progress in fact i
think his wife rachel is one of the
least likely of the possibilities and at
this point it feels a lot more like his
escalating battle with armon is gonna be
the reason she's not with him at the
airport and i guess i should make the
point that it could literally be any of
the guests at the resort someone getting
killed isn't to say someone was murdered
i think there's a good chance it could
be the result of an accident the
characters all have their flaws but none
of them seem like they would find
killing to be an easy thing to do plus
they all have their own internal stuff
going on in their own things to work out
which is really what the show's more
focused on it's not the kind of show
that's built on this central mystery
it's really rooted in these complex
characters and their affluence and
privilege provide fertile ground for
social commentary and satire i mentioned
the characters being generally unlikable
and it's impressive when you think about
how much care the writers took to keep
the scales tipped in that direction any
perceived redeeming quality is quickly
overshadowed and two-thirds of the way
through the season there are only a few
characters left who haven't revealed an
awful quality they all suck and it's
novel because you're bound to rank their
nastiness based on your own underlying
prejudices and grievances also in most
of the ongoing conflicts there's the
whole well he's not wrong kind of thing
going on for example shane is thoroughly
annoying but on the other side armin did
double book the honeymoon suite and he's
continued to lie to cover that up and
it's not doing any favors for anyone
while the casket mystery isn't the most
important thing going on in the show
it's still fun to speculate about who
might be in it so let's look at the
potential candidates except for armond
the staff are fairly undeveloped they're
there to support what feels like more
important developments in the plot with
the main cast and considering their
locals it doesn't seem like their bodies
would be flown anywhere if they were
killed i'll talk more about belinda in a
minute but up to this point she's been
one of the characters who doesn't appear
to have a dark side i don't think
killing kai or dylan would be that
impactful right now and overall don't
expect it to be one of them
kitty also seems pretty unlikely sure
she's annoying and she winds rachel up
you might be able to imagine a scenario
where things got out of hand and
something happened between those two but
shane looked angry he didn't look like
someone who was mourning the loss of a
loved one if it were rachel you would
expect that he'd be devastated they just
got married and from what we've seen
he'd probably be even more broken up if
it was his mother they seem to be very
close and he seems to take a lot of his
cues from her and yeah if you go back
and re-watch the scene he just doesn't
look like he's had that kind of loss
what's more likely is that he didn't
come out on top in the battle over the
room or he did and it was a pyrrhic
victory and in the process of getting
what he wanted in relation to armon he
took things too far he pissed off his
new bride and now he's traveling home
alone i also don't think there's a lot
pointing towards mark or nicole nicole
has the control thing going on and she's
great at injecting chaos into her
interactions with just about everyone
she takes a direct path to guide a
conversation and never fails to deliver
whatever it is that she wants to say
because of that i'd be pretty shocked if
she didn't survive in contrast mark has
been all over the place from the time
they arrived first he was sure he had
cancer then he found out about his dad
having sex with men and that information
put him on a bender since then armin has
been laying it on pretty heavy and been
pretty forward in their interactions but
things would have to go all kinds of
wrong for that to turn into him going
home in a coffin
something happening to one of their kids
seems a little more plausible olivia is
the kind of character who somewhat
performatively has a lot to say about
society and the shortcomings of her
parents she imagines herself to be
different than her family but there are
plenty of hints coming through her
relationship with paula that this might
not be the case
it's not unthinkable that she could get
involved in a situation that might put
her or someone nearby her in jeopardy
that could make for a dramatic situation
for quinn his age separates him from
being a fully formed unlikable character
he's a spoiled kid obsessed with his
electronics but he's a kid just the same
and after his gadgets all get washed
away into the ocean we see that he's
starting to open up to the world around
him
if we're thinking about the death being
an accident his diving lessons and
interest in the local boaters would put
him at a higher risk compared to the
rest of his family there's always an
impact when a young person dies and with
quinn appearing to be on a trajectory of
growth it would certainly make for a
memorable ending
the one new character is greg tanya
mistook him for a black lives matter
advocate his relative late entry into
the story makes it unclear if his death
would have much of an impact on anyone
but her there's always a chance that it
will turn out that that's exactly why
he's the one that gets killed but i
think it's too early to say
the last three characters are all
outsiders in a way and that makes them
seem like the most likely to die
paula's the friend that olivia was
allowed to bring with her and we've seen
that she has the idea that their friends
only so far as olivia knows that she has
more of everything because of that paul
has tried to keep her vacation fling
with kai a secret there appears to be
some history with olivia hooking up with
someone she was into in the past and now
we've seen that she's still being shady
there's a lot of potential for their
friendship not to make it out of the
vacation intact and as i said her
outsider status makes you wonder how
safe she is
armond is a character that's actively
spiraling and at this point he doesn't
seem capable of standing down in his
conflict with shane through his actions
he seems like the most likely candidate
to end up dead whether it be from an od
and his relapse or creating a situation
that would lead to a fatal accident it's
not immediately clear why they would
need to fly his body out if he died i
mean he's australian and of course they
could be shipping him back home to his
family but at the same time he's the
embodiment of the staff at the resort
this character has things down to a
science this is clear from his tropical
kabuki explanation to the trainee and
that centers his story around how things
turn out in his war with shane could it
end in death well we know shane won't
die he was the one that was in the flash
forward so armond is the only
possibility out of those two of course
their ongoing battle could just lead to
collateral damage and i think there's a
real possibility of that happening
that brings us to the last character and
the one i'm currently leaning towards
tanya maquad it's one syllable well two
syllables but the second part is one
syllable wad she stands out because
she's the only person traveling alone
and she's managed to put off almost all
of the other guests just by being
herself i mean she's carrying around her
mother's ashes and she hasn't been able
to let go of them and beyond just
looking for attention from a man which
is obvious in her interactions with greg
she appears to be completely rudderless
she's rich that affords her a
comfortable existence but she's an
absolute mess with belinda she's found
someone on the staff that she imagines
can solve her problems in her mind she's
able to connect in a way that she's not
able to with the other guests the people
from her class but she isn't able to
identify the power differential in how
her offer of financing a new business
affects things beyond it just being
something she wants to do she sees this
as a win-win situation and for us we can
see where belinda is coming from and
being reluctant to find hope in it
really happening that's what makes me
think tanya is the one who will die she
came alone and hasn't made any strong
connections with the mossbachers or the
patents and those people through the
lens of the story being a reflection of
the society we live in they exist in the
group that are pretty much always going
to be okay through their comments we get
the idea that mark and nicole fear a
loss of status and they worry about
their son's prospects in light of the
culture war but the reality is that
they're the ones who have the least to
worry about in the big picture on the
other hand belinda has something to lose
if things start to materialize with her
getting her own business and then tanya
were to die she would take that
opportunity with her and for now that's
what i'm guessing will happen at the end
of the series things might take a turn
in the last two episodes though i think
at its core we have a story about a
group of well-off people who see
themselves as having problems they do
have their own problems and so they run
off to hawaii to buy themselves some
relief the best resort the best scenery
and most importantly the best service
that money can buy the problem there is
the old saying that wherever you go you
take yourself with you and in the
scenario of the show they're coming
together and their intersections are
spreading those problems around i think
it should be fun to see how it all
resolves and i think that's a good place
to leave things in the comments let me
know who you think's in the casket and
how you hope to see the white lotus end
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and thanks for watching
i'll talk to you soon